today on our show we had another guest
in the cave dudes get ready to pull your
weenies it's Baldini Doug Doug Doug
that's a great intro Thank You
Baldini all day right today I'm fat man
down there
what up kids well the fat man I'm not no
we're doing this one Batman Batman I'm
Kevin Smith mark Barnard I'm gonna
3-shot cuz everyone knows he's there
yeah hey yes you asked for us we brought
you class [ __ ] Paul Dean Ian and Izzy
man anybody who worth their salt and
genre land knows exactly who this guy is
he's got a list of credits longer than
your [ __ ] dick but let's just start
with the biggest one that right now
[ __ ] means Mosca suicide squads about
to come out Harley Quinn baby daddy one
half arlequin baby daddy yeah that's
right you're looking at a man there
ain't no the best half exactly there
ain't no dude well some people get
shitty okay who's the writer who's the
yard whatever they're Harley Quinn I was
going second time I didn't want people
getting into a stand Jeff thing we love
Paul we love Bruges everybody's bumpers
and palm Bruce got together and made a
baby yeah funny how many years ago God
25 years ago 26 years ago now name
Harlequin and now she's just ready to be
born to the Maggie Mandy yeah yeah
that's one when I dreamed her up I'm
gonna wrote the first script with her
and and then and then it took like two
years after that for to finally get on
the air you know
animation takes a hell of a long time to
get going but yeah around then so 25
years ago showing you're a big animation
Weiner give him a single as he lists as
many jobs starting from Fat Albert go
Fat Albert worked with
with Cosby and that was those are the
light of my in my early years you know
because it's Bill Cosby and after my Fat
Albert and it was like an assist in all
of them because you know to Russell my
brother who I slept with amazing listen
to him you know every night and the fact
that my first job was writing Fat Albert
it was like interesting terms put you in
the world of formation that was right
yes then where do you go from there with
fellow film nation led to kind of like I
started working here and there
hanna-barbera
ruby-spears came back to film nation
worked on he-man and the Masters of the
Universe he was just a clump of plastic
they were saying well we want an
animated show about this so I was going
down to Mattel and I was going like you
do know it's all the same doll you know
he's got the same dog same body as
Skeletor and man shut up shut up shut up
making these quick and cheap and and
evil ends the same body is a sign up
shut up Chuck we just change the heads
so you've got all these giant thighs
what do we do with all these chicks all
those eman figures look like my mom my
mother's thighs childbearing hips and
the best childbearing but how deep were
you and two like were you there for the
building of Eternia did you come up with
names yeah I came up with you know some
of the sideline characters and stuff
like that like you needed a sidekick
okay move with Orko and I remember when
they were drawing up I said you don't
put a big o on his chest and they said
Oh for Orko I said no that's show or
money we're gonna make from creating the
scary having absolutely this we're
coming up with there's no McDonald out
of them and everything so but you know
some sideline care actually I can't with
really weird ass characters and then
they later made toys out of them like a
couple of years ago I came up with this
character called plugged or this iris
Warren Greenwood and I we said listen
cement to a weird world where there's a
giant bunny
who's just evil it's like okay great
done rabbit you know and I think we were
kind of inspired by Matt greatings life
in hell like what if what if he met life
in Hell rabbit we possibly couldn't draw
that so he came up with her like a
warrior rabbit and and it's so stupid
and they made a figure of it I looked at
once at the box and put it back and just
put it away in shame like all right so
he man what do you do after all a man
when I've been worked for George Lucas
the Lucasfilm money walks and droids
that was a lot of fun that was kind of
like Skywalker Ranch film school just
there for four years on the ranch it's
sort of like the fairy Kingdom you know
he's making willow and Tucker and stuff
so I got to see all that stuff being
made Ewoks and droids those were like
the saw Star Wars cartoons where they
made the really good ones you know like
Clone Wars like it's essential yeah I
was there laying in the Chapmans is
essential cartridge in the bandolier
strip if you oh yeah right now when you
think about think about Star Wars in
terms of Saturday Night Live sure in the
beginning classic asked about classic
Star Wars rights rights to the religion
then there's that period where nobody
watched for a while but somebody had to
keep the flames lit somebody had to keep
the right continuity moving forward and
that's what droids and Ewoks did like
it's easy to shoot now be like they're
not the cartoons we know and love today
without that you got nothing it was like
holiday special and nobody needs to just
remember that right now some people be
like well I'd rather not have [ __ ]
droids and Ewoks if that's all we could
have but you're talking to people that
were like in the trenches back in the
day we had Star Wars you know Empire
Return of the Jedi that was
we didn't and then we had toys and we
had to make the adventures ourselves and
the aforementioned Christmas special but
everybody oh happy life good like this
what were unhappy life day yeah this was
like an opportunity to watch the the
universe expand a little bit yeah when
you knew they weren't making any more
new stuff like I welcomed he walks to
Joy's yes
he walks definitely wasn't made for me
right droids kind of wide yeah you know
and I joined it for awhile I watched it
but that was right at the period where
I'm like I'm I'm holding up now yeah I'm
in high school maybe Star Wars isn't as
important or something like that but
that's don't ever put that down no
that's that's you're part of the Star
Wars [ __ ] legacy yeah yeah yeah and
put me in the same room with George
Lucas and creative meetings and I can't
you can't put a price on that and we're
sitting around going can I use the
bounty hunters and droids and goes you
mean like Boba Fett and I said yeah he
goes what do you think people like him
like oh this is bad you don't know
anything about it and I said it's the
design of the helmet it's that weird
black tee that goes down there it's
almost like that he was kind of like huh
I guess so because he didn't know it was
like or we gotta have another character
okay we'll come up with this guy we'll
put him in the cartoon part of the
holiday special and suddenly it was
lightning in a bottle
I don't even think he understood how
viscerally popular of that design would
become and he would sort of mystified at
least the time I was talking to and I
think he went back and saw what people
liked about it said yeah I'm gonna I
love you at the time 24 24 and you're
standing at the foot of the master yeah
I made the trilogy of our youth yeah you
know so I'm extending his brand so I'll
go over watching film Tucker and Howard
the Duck and all that [ __ ] was spilled
you were there when he was doing out of
the day yeah yeah their sense of hope
like this is it we're cracking the
comical code there was I have but I have
to admit when I saw the costume I went
right over because I saw some sculptures
where he looked like the Valmer
early the Donald that one yeah
was really ironic was over at ILM they
were doing like the shading on Roger
Rabbit single single I'm not huge yeah
they were they were doing like the
process I'm Roger Rabbit and one I'd
seen the animation come in I would go on
like that that's gotta be Howard the
Duck no not this guy in the costume
because you can see the the fleshy part
around the eyes it looks like a mask it
looks like you couldn't fill it in you
know at least white it out a little bit
and they said no this is where we want
to go with it it looks real to us and I
said no man Roger Rabbit that's let's
see here away and that's gonna kick this
thing's ass and unfortunately it did you
know I think just visually it was just
it was too out of step with what the
what everybody loved about the comic
with the incongruity of humans talking
to a cartoon character
remember the awkward scene with the duck
prophylactic oh yeah like you know how
people like I want to bring my kid to
Deadpool because I'd have to explain
pegging try explaining duck [ __ ] and
then dumping rubber you know that was a
pg-13 movie yeah those drives in a world
you did there's one story I'd to tell
about Howard the Duck is like when I was
working up there my sister Jane was
always pissed at me she goes okay
Goonies came out he didn't take me to
the premiere that and then young
Sherlock Holmes and I didn't get to see
that were you taking me to the premiere
of something I said okay well you want
to go see Howard the doctor she goes
sure so at the end of Howard the Duck
she just kind of looked at me and
punched me
flash forward like I don't know how many
years later we're going to see guardians
of galaxy and we want to see Guardians
Agassi yeah and so she's really loving
it loving all the way right up until the
very end and when she sees Howard the
Duck come on she goes let's still give
it a [ __ ] about yeah you were right
though your time is gonna prove you
right yeah
right so after he walks and droids where
do you make the move at a weird little
sideways excursion into trying to
recreate beany and Cecil the bob
clampett show with John Chris Pelusium
Bruce Tim's first time with John John
instead be famous Turkey yeah because he
had just come off working with back
sheet on Mighty Mighty Mouse sniffing of
the snorting of the flower yeah yeah oh
yeah yeah and and then so he loves Bob
Clampett and he was very close to the
Clampett family and he he came on to
redo it boy we were at ABC at the time
just did not understand funny they did
not want to take a chance
CBS Elise was taking chances of things
like pee-wee's Playhouse and a couple of
other things and ABC was just rigid and
they just wanted only the very very pure
aisle version of okay it's a kid in a
sea serpent and it's it's whacking goofy
it's not really funny
and it was just it was just a fatal
combination like Chuck Lorre was the
story editor they wouldn't let him be
funny and this was you know like he
started off in animation then he just
said you know I can't deal with this and
he went off and you know we were
slogging away on beany and cecil and
bruce on that was the first time I work
with Bruce was he was storyboarding
Bruce and those cartoons yeah really
that's where you guys met before Warner
brother that's where we met before
Warner Brothers and then beany and Cecil
exploded tremendously everybody got
fired yet the show just imploded do they
even make a single episode or not they
made five episodes and you can see some
of them online and you know they're not
bad but they weren't what you know
you've got these young guys are really
creative and they're really at the time
there was real no out really no outfit
outlook for them there was no late-night
TV there was no internet there was no
Cartoon Network so it's if you wanted to
do something you had to go in and try
and do it along Saturday morning lines
does the only way they buy a cartoon
from you and but all these guys really
wanted to do rude exciting stuff that
wouldn't exist for another ten years so
it was just like the right talent of the
time you know he had was like a spike in
mic animation carnival yeah ever wasn't
it like super easy so underground yeah
yeah go to a big city and see it yeah
like that [ __ ] is expensive to do so it
was gonna pay for it that's that's the
other thing you know so you have to go
where the money is and sometimes you
have to if you want the stuff to get on
TV
you know tailor it down but I remember
going to lunch with John a couple of
times we'd sit there laughing our asses
off over great gags and we wanted to put
these things and they have to go back
and pitch it to the network and they
just sit there like you know look like
Mount Rushmore all these stone face
that's like we don't get it and so that
imploded and then I got a call from were
brothers like they were gonna start up
and they were gonna do Tiny Toon
Adventures and with Steven Spielberg and
I had met some of those folks from
working at Lucas and they said you know
Kay won't you come in and I let's stop
right there real quick yeah and just
acknowledge the fact that in the span of
a couple years you worked with both
George Lucas yeah and then Steven
Spielberg one on you know extending his
franchise yeah with joys and he walks
the other with reintroducing the Looney
Tunes by way of younger characters to a
whole new generation with his signature
on it yeah yeah what the like whose dick
did you [ __ ] sausage nerd Forrest Gump
exactly wandering through awesomeness
like young Indiana Jones show really
Armstrong Amit's Teddy Roosevelt he
meets all these great figures of history
they might have been 90 years old just
as rent man so what was Spielberg like
to like were you there in a room gone we
want to do plucky duck and he's like yes
amazingly collaborative and and just so
engaging and a lot of fun and he would
come in and you really want to be a part
of the processing he loves cartoons and
your remember to Amblin to his office to
the office yes basically it's just hung
with animation and tremendous ah aren't
working everything and he would come in
and he talks he talks of talking and you
can mention a cartoon and he'll go right
to a scene where there's like emotional
impact from
cartoon any cartoon he's seen and he
truly loves them and so it was very easy
to talk and pitch to him ideas and when
he would say no he'd say I don't wanna
do that because of this and it's like
okay great and he'd always point to a
different direction so a lot of
enthusiasm a lot of creativity a lot of
support and there was a lot of fun
working with him on Tiny Toons and I
guess last next time I worked with him a
little bit was on freakazoid after that
and some of the other stuff where did
where did Bruce go to Warner Brothers
with you or you guys just tapping him he
was already there he was there yeah they
had sort of put the call out after a
beany and Cecil imploded the Warner's
was going to be hiring because Stephen
had done Tiny Toon Adventures and he
really loved getting his feet wet with
the Warner Brothers characters and he
didn't really want to go back and try
and remake bugs and Daffy but he said
let's try and do like a new generation
with that same spirit and bugs and Daffy
and everybody can be in it but let's
really try and come up with something
else
so Tiny Toons got their feet warm and
then Animaniacs and freakazoid and a
bunch of other stuff and and then his
own stuff that he's doing now over it
over there at DreamWorks so how does
that now you do win awards on Tiny Toons
oh yeah yeah I want to come joy what
Emmy joy is every night oh yeah a couple
of them the first one was first time we
won the Emmy was really great
winning was fine and then and then after
that we won for writing for a Batman for
the mr. freeze episode which was the
best one because I took my dad to the
Emmys and you know it's like I had no
idea it was just like it's really great
how awesome you got a hold on me up in
front of your dad yeah it was it was it
was like a once-in-a-lifetime thing was
so happy
tremendous all right so wait a second
you're working on Tiny Toons Animaniacs
and they consumed it is
yeah Batman wasn't was between was
between Animaniacs Tiny Toons and then
and then freakazoids so we were working
on Tiny Toons and then gene mccurdy said
they're gonna make an they're gonna make
more Batman movies we really want to do
a series that kind of ties in maybe not
exactly to those movies but kind of the
feel and the tone of that world so she
put the call out among the staff people
to come up with with tanks and I think
Bruce went back to his office and he
took ten minutes and he drove up for up
that you know the plastic shot of Batman
standing there and she said okay you're
on the show and then Eric Radonski came
in and he'd done a background painting
on black paper and she said that looks
really great and so they became the the
visual designers and the creators of the
show and I worked with Bruce I'm writing
a Bible and we got that kicked off and
then I then the show kinda was getting
up on its feet we didn't know when the
show was gonna start or anything and
Tiny Toons was standing up for another
season and we were writing home video so
I went back to do that and then I left
to write a movie for about half a year
and then someone I came when Alan
Burnett called me up he had he was he'd
come over from hanna-barbera to kind of
run the writing over there and I'd never
met him before and he said we would like
to have you come back here and work on
staff and I said I don't know if I'm up
for it and goes well he writes and spec
scripts for us because you like the
development you did not Batman so we
wrote a couple of early scripts you like
those and then he said we come back full
time
listen yeah okay because by that point
he had kind of figured out what the show
needed to be there than other writers
that kind of came and went and the show
had gone alternated from being to not
about Batman to too much of him as good
old Batman like you know throw the show
airs by that point always it still just
they were seeing well that was about a
year and a half away from Moore never
had air before I never had air you know
K they were in development a long time
yeah the first thing that Bruce and Eric
did was a real short little film of
Batman surprising some thugs on top of a
roof you know some classic old-style
gangsters and Gordon coming up with a
gun and chasing him off and you see him
fly away and everything it was really
stunning looking and
part of that same field was incorporated
in the title points yeah and but yeah
took a while to get sorted out of at
least a year and a half of scripting
before we got to the the first air date
and was there a mandate to be even close
to the movies or no there else was
between and if I remember correctly
Batman happened right and then Batman
Returns was about to happen is that when
they said hey let's do a Batman show
somewhere between the two yeah I think
Batman Returns came out in the summer of
92 92 be right and we premiered that
fall yeah so on Fox yeah I remember yeah
so there were certain things that we
tried to incorporate like a look at the
penguin the look of Catwoman the fact
that she was blonde in the movie that
that we made Selina Kyle blonde at least
at first and there were certain visual
cues that we took from there and but
mostly it was sort of be true to the
tone of those movies but go your own way
and so we tried to at least give some
hints to you know visually to that world
now even to tell the story so incisor
for those he a good assumes every comic
books his first comic book the how does
Harley Quinn come into play because
that's you're working on a lot of
characters I existed that's character
whole cloth created just for this show
right right well you know Harley was not
part of the the DC Universe before that
of course and she wasn't even part of
the development that we had come up with
originally I was writing a few freelance
episodes for Alan Burnett and I was
writing this one called Joker's favor
where a guy you know kind of crosses
paths with the Joker and then you know
it's the Joker you know kind of preying
on an ordinary guy just because it's
sort of funny and I had to give the
Joker some henchmen and I thought what
about a girl and you know what kind of a
character should she be should she be
like just a rank-and-file hench person
or should she be funny like on the Adam
West show and I be and I like the idea
of somebody who would kind of make jokes
and kind of pissed the Joker off but he
would have her around for some reason
and you know and a cute girl is always
fun so I came up with
the character and I named her Harley
Quinn because I thought oh that keeps
with the clown motif and I remember I
even did a rough design Burstyn looked
at it went better and they actually made
a figurine out of that last year her
original dry yeah when I was drawing her
I was going like okay this was 1960
Barbara Eden would probably be playing
like the girl henchman role like Jill
st. John or something so I came up with
a blonde in a miniskirt and Bruce was
just like they drew the Harley thank God
that we all know and love and and so
then she was in that episode and she was
people liked her they thought she was
sort of funny she didn't detract from
the Joker and then we began doing some
more episodes and it's like let's drop
her out of a couple because we don't
want her to you know we don't want if
she's we see too much of her she's gonna
get really irritating so every you know
two or three episodes she'd show up and
people liked her the directors liked her
and it's sort of like Bugs Bunny nobody
really thinks I'm gonna the character is
all born you know saying what's up top
doc and all his catchphrases and
everything she evolved a little bit over
time and I think that she really became
crystallized about a year after we'd
gone on the air Bruce and I sat down to
write the Mad Love story and and then a
lot of her backstory came up and and you
know a lot of the pathos and the
dimension with the carrots to talk about
that real quick so mad love was DC
saying hey do a comic book right so they
approach you or you approach them they
approached they approached us I mean it
was it was very casual it was we had
gone back there early on in the
development stages to New York Bruce and
I had taken a trip back there to look at
you know to talk to DC and get some
ideas just wandering around the city
looking at you know the architecture and
everything and what we might incorporate
from that and then so I think the door
was always open Denny O'Neil and Mike
Carlin and Paul Levitz and everybody
there was very open to the idea because
we had we'd shown that we were very
collaborative and we appreciated a lot
you know source material like you guys
weren't like is it a [ __ ] your Grandpa's
back
man this is new Berman lies reached into
their toy box and played with all of
their toys yeah them well did him
justice yeah yeah and so they said yeah
if you want to you know come up with
something so we came up with a mad love
story and you know ever done any comic
stuff before then I've done one or two
little things here and there I had done
you know a friend of mine had a you know
when it started a black and white
company called Claypool comics and he
didn't Elvira comic books I wrote an
issue for him you know and a few little
things here there and then but Harley
the mad love story was the first thing
that I the first DC job that I ever did
and it was like full talk about you know
lucky fluke know now I mean Bruce worked
as his is put his heart and soul into
that you know was he was he was drawing
every night and and coloring and he did
all the color models on it and
everything and and he would come in the
next day with these pages and you been
up all day all night you know drawing
and inking and everything and I think it
was like a learning process for him
because he'd done some comic book work
before but nothing on this on this level
and so we just you know we made it as
good as we could and now what happens
like did you feel an instant impact with
mad love because it's kind of historic
like the characters in their cartoons
and that's all fine and good and she
became very popular there but like mad
love instant know the sounds were seven
institutionalized terminal yeah way even
before DC said she's officially part of
our universe which would happen way a
couple years later right i I remember
the reverberations of mad love of people
being like oh my god yes this book is
seriously like it's it's done in a very
cartoony style and Bruce's style right
but it's like a seriously well told
story you know I kind of blew away
everything that was in vogue at the
moment it was a book you could give your
girlfriend yeah right right because the
Bruce's art is so clean and crystal and
the storytelling is so pure there was
never any barriers for entry yes that's
why my kids named Harley Quinn is I gave
my then girlfriend now wife Jennifer
copy and Mad Love and I have a picture
she's in a tub reading it that's a good
creepy took a picture
but I couldna 90s when you weren't
supposed to do that either so but you
know she's sitting there reading mad
loving the time she got out of the tub
and she was like Harley Quinn would be a
great name for a kid if we ever ever kid
yeah okay and we did have a kid yeah I'm
out of the Quinn but you're right I was
able to give she was not a genre fan she
and read comics or anything familiar
with like the big ones but you know she
was like you're always talking about
comic books you have something I could
read and I was like I do yeah that was
perfect like you know I couldn't hand
her dark night returns as a commitment
but this was like well let's see if you
take this and should I get enough to
name I get me now and again you find
like the sexually-transmitted comics
it's like hey look Sandman
give that me out last man give that a
read and that love was like hey you like
Batman you know what this is read this
creature misty loves preachers yeah yeah
they're all inclusive
yes yeah I mean - it's not like here's a
story about that one guy doing all those
things it's like this is a story about
the Joker's girlfriend yep she's the
main character and the Joker is almost
secondary everything about it is
intriguing though where's Batman he's in
it a few times yeah yeah it's really
about her
I'm created the anti-heroin in many ways
yeah you know it's it's so cinematic in
a lot of ways they're in Bruce's a
phenomenal storyboard artist and a
director and there were just so many
touches that you'd expect to see in a
movie like when the Joker's maybe she
calls up the Joker you know that says
that she's trapped Batman he goes you
have Batman huh he's like looking
through his plans and he goes uh-huh
okay and the next panel he's screaming
you have who tied up where and the next
panel isn't him running out or anything
it's an old man being run over in the
street by a speeding car
visual kind it's like a cutout of an
action movie that would just go to that
and it just sort of carries you from one
panel to another you don't need any
dialogue and then it's just you know
that's what he thinks and it's just you
know it made it gave it a magic all its
own so the character takes off the show
has taken off what do you do what do you
follow that man they might have made
series you did Batman Robin adventures
but then Batman Beyond follows that yeah
we've done Batman Robin adventures then
Superman and then the super that's right
yeah it's a woman who for Batman went
super in a whole crew pretty much soul
crew and I love that room too but that
was a Brainiac stream yeah made Brainiac
cool yeah you did two villains I mean
you did all everything on row you did
justice son but you did two corny-ass
Billings real justice in those both no
series mr. freeze yeah in Batman like
you redefine eternity of a Shakespearean
level tribe tragic character and then in
the other one Superman was Brainiac yeah
Brainiac was always like he makes Lex
Luthor exactly yeah I never knew what it
was before and until now we made him
[ __ ] badass look that's a cool
backstory of like I collect I'm the
repository of all knowledge of the
planet right and I get that knowledge
and then make sure that planet yeah it's
like they get perfectly villainous yeah
but also also like phonological yes he's
just a computer condom and he was
created out of the Kryptonians hubris
like okay you know Brainiac will solve
all our problems
oh yeah he'll solve his problems he's
gonna get his ass out of there while you
blow such a great series all right so
who went over from Batman animators
quite a lot of folks Eric had left at
that time Alan Burnett and I had gone
over there some of the writers had gone
over there a lot of them just we had add
a lot of new designers and come on
during the run of
Batman they went over there Bruce wanted
to rethink the visual style which is why
I changed the style for the new Batman
adventures because he wanted the two
worlds to look together so to work
together he felt like to root to go in
and design Superman that's gonna be a
brighter palette a more streamlined
design and so he redesigned a lot of the
Batman characters to fit into that world
a little better and that's why I came up
with the the the you know more elegant
streamlined more optimistic design at
metropolis so you're saying that like a
character who's like kind of light and
sunny and bright yeah and a character
who's a little dark shouldn't
necessarily be in the dark world they
should kind of meld a little bit better
what's great about that is like they're
Werner's really let him rethink you know
everything they could have said no no
just stick to the model sheets we've
done this we have toys that look like
this just just stay the course it's like
no you want to read redo it go go ahead
you know make a vision of Batman that
fits in with the new Superman world and
everything has sort of evolved you know
since then Fred because the look of
Justice League is slightly different and
then looks of some of the directive
videos that he's doing is slightly
different than that I mean you can all
you know trace it back but you know you
look at the early Bugs Bunny cartoons
the early cartoons
Tex Avery did or nothing like the later
wants it Chuck even look like Bugs
Bunny's a kid you'd watch a movie like
that must be Bugs Bunny's cousin yeah
yeah yeah okay so you go from Superman
to Justice League to Batman Beyond right
then when did you leave the DC Universe
what you do after that you created
Jingle Bell oh yeah for comics than ever
in everything and then Warner Brothers
iced ice
I came to kind of like I was a little
tired than men in capes mm-hmm I love
the Looney Tunes so they were going to
do duck Dodgers and they jumped on that
and I
there we go and that was that's a lot of
fun you know to work with spike grant
Toni sir boning and just go back and do
our take on you know classic Looney tune
short and that was a lot of fun and and
then the business kind of changed you
know the new people came in running the
studio and the writers deals changed and
it was it got a little harder to be
there so I had an opportunity to go off
and work on the first season of Lost so
I just said well I got a which is not a
bad person and do you think that's the
pedigree like well how did you wind up
on loss then like man we love your
episodes I'm Batman
it was something you know what happened
was you know Brian Burke you know what
yeah and works with JJ he I had met him
through our good friend David Mandel and
he and he always liked me and said you
know you got kind of a weird skew and
everything you know you've got a weird
imagination and everything and we're
doing the show about people trapped on
an island do you want to and when we
need writers with kind of out their
imaginations to kind of make a leap of
faith you might have a job for a year
you might be often in three weeks but
you want to come over and meet everybody
so I came over and I talked to Damon
Lindelof and JJ was there that day and
we all got to talking and about a week
later Damon called up and said yeah I'd
like to have you joined this group of
writers we're gonna develop the show and
so while he would and JJ were writing
the pilot the other three writers and I
were kind of coming up with ideas and
pitching them to JJ and Damon about the
about that characters in the island and
everything so you were the development
of smoke monster of like all that season
one so well little bits here and there I
mean you know the monster was something
that they had cooked up and everything
but defining certain things about the
island and certain characterizations I
remember we one day we all wrote down
the names of all the characters and we
put them in a hat and everybody drew
three names and it's like okay for the
next two nights you're gonna be writing
nothing but these characters go home and
define these three characters so I drew
Sawyer Locke and son and I took him home
and I wrote all those you know
everything I could think of about these
characters that we've discussed in the
office and added a bunch of stuff and we
all came in and pitched them and then
everybody kind of swapped characters and
we all
kind of gave it a shot and then
ultimately JJ and Damon made the maybe
final call on them and and then it
wasn't even until like they were
actually shooting some of the episodes
it would be like oh I got a great idea
what if Locke never stands up we never
see his likes and then we reveal II
spent in a wheelchair all this time so
that was you know Damon brought in this
this great idea which was sort of like a
total surprise you know and and a lot of
stuff was thought of that way like you
know all the the real the quick turns
and everything because once we serve
established here's the meat and potatoes
of it they would come in and they'd to
everything else to it most TV writers go
their entire careers never working on a
show that has any cultural impact like
at all to be able to have Batman on one
hand and then [ __ ] lost on the other
hand yeah like come on dude that's like
he ain't even done influence in the
culture video games video games your
work done because you know world men so
it's all movies and don't think your
critical reaches back to your ruse
remember these kids today are all about
the Batman this yeah Matan stuff what
did you work on well there was the et
Atari that was did the Arkham games so
the first target yeah which was what
Arkham Asylum and then I was working
with Rocksteady and I got over to
England to meet them and and it was it
was really terrific you know working
with them and with the crew of artists
over there and then after that came
Arkham City as you get old side and um
and that was another it was like writing
an animated feature it was like two or
three years of just working on the
project writing and rewriting and it
would work you know for the space of
like about a year just writing you know
all the little things like you know
Batman runs down the hall and talks to a
guard which way to go that way Batman
then I reread the same way have you seen
the Joker
yes he's over here you know and so
you're writing the same thing over and
over and trying to add a little bit to
it because they've gotta animate all the
different various choices you can so how
long of a draft is it to write a game
like
oh they're ever a onefold you have like
do they ever put it in front of you and
be like there's your script yeah I mean
it's like like one of those reams of
paper you buy it staples or something
like that it's it's just 500 pages or
something holy and then they go through
the recording and they have to record
everything for Kevin Conroy must be shot
for a week after recording all the
different Batman the you know of the
different Batman lines and everything it
was fun it was fun seeing it all come
together was fun seeing it play out and
people said how long did it take you to
finish the games and it's like I've
never finished a game because I just
like going and being Batman I'll just
swing from building the building maybe
I'll drive the car for a bit
so did you do all three of them no or
asylum in Arkham City they did Arkham
origins which was done by a game company
in Canada and then they did Arkham
Arkham night yeah what is this so when
are you done right in the video game
because don't think upgrade games and
[ __ ] like so would you have to be like
if they ever did an upgrade package
you're like I have to write a few more
lines when he meets a random or
something like yeah no they have they
have writers on staff to do that there
was AI worked with a very good writer
who was there in charge of rocks days a
story development a Paul Paul Crocker
and he and I would run things by each
other a lot and I would write all the
drafts and give them to him and he would
go through and do some rewriting and
changes and he'd write stuff as well but
he was there on staff so it was in there
in-house guy so whenever there was an
expansion package or you know like
Harley Quinn's revenge or something like
that he would write that or he and his
team what do I was I was there mostly
for the big picture stuff and for a lot
of the the cutscene dialogue and a lot
of you know at least the first two a lot
of in games and game stuff now we're on
the verge not the very eve but like in
the summer Suicide Squad is gonna happen
yeah and Harley no longer belongs to you
no longer belongs to me and hen
she belongs to everybody my mom well my
mom knows hourly Quinn's name yeah her
granddaughter but everybody's mother
gonna know Harley cows as much as they
know Batman and the Joker you've added
[ __ ] spoke to the wheel people jump
in there they play with what exists it's
nice a rich enough tapestry oh you don't
even feel the need to bring [ __ ] to it
like what I want to ride from them I
just want to play with your characters
but you brought a character into the mix
that now stands shoulder to shoulder
with characters that are 50 60 sometimes
70 years old yeah has that [ __ ] feel
dude when do you drop the mic or do you
like there's more I wanted Oh nowhere
near dropping the mic I mean you know
it's a Harley Quinn's a start for me I
mean you know I want to just keep going
and create other stuff you know my own
characters and characters for other
people and I just the great thing about
Harley Quinn is that it gave me a lot of
confidence as a creator and say like hey
I can do this you know whether I work
with really talented collaborators or if
I go off and try and do something on my
own I may not be able to hit the
bullseye ever again in my life but at
least I'll keep trying so and that's
that's the best thing about about her
but I love it that people have embraced
a character so much when I see you know
little girls come up to the house of
Halloween and they're dressed like
Harley Quinn it's so gratifying and when
I see their dad's dress the same way
it's dad here's three more Snickers bar
for you you got you you've got what the
character is above your hips so watch
as one of the dads you have a reaction
to like first time I saw Harley in an
Arkham game I wasn't dressed like Harley
Quinn yeah from the cartoon yeah I was
like what the
I got prim and proper yeah yeah like
suddenly like this is too much this is
you have is you have you ever reacted to
an incarnation of Harley Quinn where
you're like this goes too far oh no not
really I mean early on I would I you
know I went to a couple of conventions
and I'd be an artists alley and I'd see
artists who would do things various
commissions of the characters and who
lewd ones right yeah yeah and those two
and some of those I bought one or two
before I had the kid but oh that's hot
yeah it's fine you know whatever you
know whatever people like is great it's
but I like I have seen a lot of guys
dressed up like Harley Harley is very
liberating then I'll say I love being
Harley Quinn because she's kind of goes
beyond just a you know a female
character and she's sort of the sprite
that embodies I'll just do whatever the
hell I want and the hell with anybody
else and that's terrific and so I you
know I can't be one of those guys who
gets like he creates something and then
for the rest of my career saying oh I
did that one big thing and I'm really
sorry over it it was like no you know
the character is not really in my head
anymore she's out there she's not for
everybody and I and I think that's great
you know so everybody enjoy all right so
now what we did was told you about
Paul's very massive career so that we
could get to talking about what Paul's
doing right now you know you see this
kids this is what they call a comic book
yep this is where the movies and tells
you sure
oh so much come from this source
material on the next episode of fat man
Batman we're gonna talk about this this
is Paul's latest book and I guarantee
Paul's months of 10 we heard about some
Hemis we down some Annie's yep
what else you want in this world
meissner's as well as is Guild Awards so
goddamn it all right he's gonna add
another award with this book I guarantee
it man we're gonna talk about it on the
very next episode a fat man died Batman
come back man you'll see me Kevin Smith
in him mark barnard him same fat time
same fat channel is called youtube.com
slash Kevin Smith
hey man it's me Kevin Smith thanks for
watching do me a favor click that thing
below that says subscribe every time you
click that you save a baby kitten from
murder